[Music]
stockpiling tall fescue for winter
grazing is definitely the most
economical feeding strategy for cow calf
operations in kentucky but we're always
going to need a little bit of hay in our
feeding operation
and it's important to understand the
quality of the hay that you're feeding
when you understand the quality of the
hay you're feeding you can supplement
that hay so that you don't lose
condition on your cows
now when we sample hay we need to sample
it by a lot
and a lot is one field
and one harvest of hay so say for
example
field a cutting first cutting would be
one lot of hay
that needs to be sampled separately from
say the second cutting from that field
or the third cutting from that field or
the first cutting from another field so
we sample by the lot
that's really important and the second
thing that's really important is that we
get a good sample and we do that by
using
a coring tool so we don't want to just
take a piece of hand pull it out of the
sample and send it in for
pull it out of the bale and send it in
for analysis
we want to actually take a bale core and
when we sample a lot we'd like to get
somewhere between
15 and 20 cores per halot
and then we composite those samples
together
mix them up and send the whole sample in
for analysis and i'll show you why we
want to send the whole sample in
in a minute after we core a few bales
so it's important when we're sampling
hay that we use a probe to sample the
hay with
for round bales we want to sample hay
from the side
and for rectangular bales large square
barrels or small square bells we want to
sample the bales from the end
and again we want to get 20 cores per
lot
and then submit all those cores to the
lab and do not separate them
into a smaller size sample
one of the important things to remember
when we take a heat sample is that we
want to submit the whole sample so never
subdivide it
you want the lab to grind the whole
sample and the reason why is if you look
at the bottom there's lots of little
fine material at the bottom
when we separate it we often grab just
this coarse material and that really
changes the
quality analysis of this forage so it's
important to submit the whole sample and
let them grind it into a homogenous
size and then they can subdivide it at
the lab
all right so once we get the sample
taken out in the field
it will come into the lab and then we
will dry the sample overnight
so the procedure for doing that is that
we take the sample from
our our bag from the field and we
transfer preferred into a paper sack
and we want to make sure we get the
whole sample in there
and that we don't miss any of the fine
material in the bottom of the bag okay
once we get the sample in here
we'll weigh it on the scale and we'll
record what we call the fresh weight on
the bag
so this sample weighs 49.9 grams
[Applause]
we'll just write that right on our bag
okay once we get the sample weighed
we'll place that sample in the dryer
overnight the dryer is set to around 55
degrees celsius which would be the
equivalent of about 130 degrees
and we'll dry it overnight now drive any
remaining moisture in that sample off
and we'll be able to determine the
driveway of the sample the reason that
we need the
dry matter on the sample is that all the
rations are balanced on the dry matter
basis
all right it's been overnight and we're
getting the sample out again and we're
going to re-weigh it to determine the
dry matter
all right so once we get the dry weight
on this we'll copy the dryer weight down
and record it on our data sheet
all right now we're going to head up to
the grinding uh facility and we're going
to grind this sample to get it ready for
forage quality analysis
all right so we've got our sample that
we've dried overnight
in the lab and we're ready to grind it
at this point in time so we use a two
stage grinding process we grind through
a wiley mill through a two millimeter
screen first
and then we'll grind through a second
grinder called a ud
cyclone sample mill for our second stage
of grinding
i'm going to open this up any things
that are left we'll put in this
okay and then we'll undo this sample
collection bottle
and just dump that in there and now we
have a pretty homogeneous sample
so instead of having a lot of large
particles and small
particles it's pretty much all two
millimeters or less
okay so we're now going to grind through
a ud cyclum sample mill
and this is the second grinder this has
a one millimeter screen in it
so we're going to go ahead and turn this
on
[Music]
so we've ground it through the ud cyclum
sample mill now we're going to transfer
that ground sample which is very fine
almost like a powder now
into our sample bag okay the goal of the
grinding process is to go from a
heterogeneous sample so a sample with
large and small pieces in it
to a very homogeneous sample and that's
what we've done here you can see that
all the particles are now about the same
size and here less than one millimeter
all right so we started with a hay bale
and we used a hayprobe to get a cord
sample
we took that cord sample into the lab we
weighed it
dried it and re-weighed it and then we
went up to our grinding facility and we
ground that sample through a two-stage
grinding process
and we ended up with this which is
essentially the hay
but in a powder form now we're ready to
analyze this hay for
forage quality and we're going to use a
technique called near-infrared
spectroscopy
and what we do is we take a cell we call
these ring cups
it has a quartz glass in the bottom and
we dump that sample into this cell then
we put a foam back in there just to hold
that forged tight against the glass
and we just brush the excess forged dust
off of there
and we're ready to take this to the near
furred spectrophotometer
and analyze it all right about 80
percent of the samples that are analyzed
for forage quality in the united states
are analyzed using a technology called
near infrared spectroscopy
and essentially what the near infrared
spectrophotometer does is it
takes light and it shines light in the
near infrared spectrum
onto the sample and then it measures
what gets reflected back
and then we can correlate what gets
reflected back
to different forage quality parameters
very precisely
for example crude protein acid detergent
fiber neutral detergent fiber
digestibility and so forth so
right now we're ready to analyze this
sample so we're going to go ahead and
put the sample
into the machine
and then we'll come up here and hit scan
so now we have the sample scanned we
need to go in and predict that sample
using a
an equation that's maintained by the
near infrared
spectroscopy consortium so it's an
equation that's based on wet chemistry
and then reference back to the near
infrared spectrum
so these are the results so in this file
we have 12 samples the
the 13 samples the 13 sample is a sample
that we just scanned
and each one of these windows is
different this is dry matter
we've got 91 almost 92 percent dry
matter in this particular sample
we can go down to crude protein we've
got about 11 and a half percent crude
protein in this sample
and we have a whole bunch of different
constituents on this list that we can
look at
and find out their digestibility or um
or fiber content now we've got our
sample taken
and we send it into the lab and we got
our results back
now the hay sampling is really worthless
unless we actually do something with
those results so what we want to do
is we want to use those results to help
us manage our hay feeding program
and so what we get back we'll get an
estimate of energy and an estimate of
crude protein and then a dry matter
value for each one of those samples
and we can take that information and put
it into what we call
the uk cow forage supplement tool
and what this is is is a way that we can
figure out how much of a supplement we
may or may not need to feed with that
particular lot of hay
so what to use this we need the dry
matter of the hay
we need the crude protein value the
neutral detergent fiber
that's an estimate of how much of that
hay the animal can actually eat
and then we need an estimate of the
energy and that's total digestible
nutrients
and those will all be on your your hay
results when you get it back from the
forged testing lab
and then the last thing we need to know
is a stage of production of the of the
cow
is she lactating with a calf or is she
dry
if we have that information we can put
that into the supplement tool which is
available online
or you can go to your extension office
and your extension agent can help you
with it
and i've got a couple examples here so
in this particular example
we've got a hay lot that has 8.6
crude protein that's a pretty pretty low
crude protein
and it's got an energy value or a tdn
value of 53 so that's pretty low also
so this is definitely going to need some
supplement when we put this information
in our hay supplementation tool
it spits out a a number of different
supplements and how much of each one of
those supplements we would need to feed
to meet the requirements of a lactating
brood cow
so for example uh if we were going to
feed soybean hulls we'd have to feed
the hay as much as it could eat plus
10.6 pounds of soybean holes per day for
this particular hay lot
now keep in mind this hay was a pretty
low low quality hay
the second halo i just wanted to mention
to you was was a much higher quality hay
lot
we had a crude protein concentration of
over 12 percent
which should meet the crude protein
requirements of a lactating brew cow
and then we had an energy or a tdn value
of around 58.7 per percent
uh the requirement would be around 60
percent for a lactating brood capsule
just a little bit low in energy
and as a result of the higher hay
quality
instead of having to feed 10.6 pounds of
soybean holes
we would only need to feed around two
pounds of soybean holes for this
particular lot of hay
to keep to supply the nutrients that a
lactating brew cow needs